they put the protesters in buses to
start off with 400 that was 1200. the
last number I heard was that they
captured about 1700 people and they
bring them to the federal police
training facility in Brasilia uh stick
them in the gymnasium no food no water
no bathrooms young kids no food old
women uh dehydrated uh
Intel says and it's been pretty well
verified that at least one person's died
that day I heard two people now they say
it's up to four or five uh and they
basically create a gulag which are being
called in Brazil lulux Lula gulags yeah
Port Monto uh and now after two days of
that that was Monday and Tuesday they
let the women and children go uh by the
way the images of old people sitting in
puddles of their own urine because
they're no bathrooms sweltering
conditions no food no water uh they let
the older the older women and the women
and children go and on the condition
that we have these floating around a
denunciation page you have to sign it to
be released saying I am a terrorist I
assaulted democracy and this now has
them on lists they will never get a job
again
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
journalist an author and a Lincoln
fellow at the Claremont Institute
Matthew tiermond Matthew finally welcome
to the Reuben report how are you it's an
honor to be with you Dave you you forgot
the most important honorific friend and
friend you are one of the people in our
little Florida crew here our little
Florida Freedom crew uh basically this
is home base for sanity throughout the
world uh I've wanted to have you on for
for quite some time because you know
there's this whole thing well I know you
know this there is this whole situation
let's say happening in Brazil which has
been unfolding after these elections for
the last couple months I've only talked
about it maybe two or three times on the
show it is not my area of expertise but
the crazier it seems to get out there
with the visuals of the protesters and
everything else it seems to me the more
the mainstream media is ignoring it and
that's one of the things that always
lights up in my mind like oh mainstream
media is ignoring it we better pay
attention to it you basically have been
I don't know possibly the most outspoken
person from an American perspective on
what's going on in Brazil so let's do
this can you give me 30 seconds on your
background why people should trust you
on this topic and then let's do a little
Brazil 101 and then get people caught up
to speed on what's going on over there
right now sure uh as I said great to be
with you and you know thank you from you
know on my behalf as well as brazilian's
behalf because they feel very very
ignored and I've become someone of their
voice sort of for the Western press from
a right-wing perspective a conservative
perspective an honest perspective uh as
they've been totally uh their voice has
been negated as their laws have been
abrogated and I you know I didn't expect
Brazil to be my beat I'm an
investigative journalist and a political
activist I wear my Politics on my sleeve
everybody knows it this is not you know
my uh my vocation professionally I do
not make money as an activist or in
campaigns or in journalism I do it
because of the Love of the Game and the
belief in truth to power I you know we
have mutual friends like James O'Keefe
I'm on the board of project Veritas uh I
help uh manage a group in Chicago to
open the books that uh does forensic
quality in the public sector all things
I believe are important to you know make
a more honest Society because our
society is is as broken as it's ever
been I did not expect Brazil to be my
beat I've been covering a lot of intro
National geopolitics from a European
perspective I'm a Polish dual citizen I
live in Europe a good chunk of the time
I've certainly covered Russia Ukraine
especially from the Polish perspective
given that they're sort of in the line
of fire but you know I cover the
Sovereign movements in Europe
westphalian sovereignty as expressed in
politics whether it's Poland or Hungary
or the right-wing parties in Sweden and
Spain and France and Germany et cetera
Etc I didn't expect to do Brazil but
here we are I went there for CPAC in 21
with Jason Miller gave a speech about
exactly this honest media Free Press
culture war and uh lo and behold as we
were exiting the country we were
detained by Alexander Marias the Supreme
Court which we will speak about uh and
interrogated and asked to write down the
names of who we met with the politicians
the activists the journalists and it had
a very stalinous feel to it you know
give us the uh the next tranche of our
enemies list of course we did not comply
with that and from that I you know
germinate an interest I want to
understand exactly hold on I gotta I
gotta pause you there if you're trying
to leave a country yes
they ask you for the list they detain
you you don't comply that's not an easy
thing to do I think you've glossed over
how that ended
well they said we were not under arrest
we were part of what they're called the
fake news investigation and we'll talk
about this for years the court and the
burgeoning judicial autocracy uh had put
every one of the political enemies of
the court of the Lula Camp into this box
of uh by being critical of the court or
any of the things in government that was
not aligned with bolsonaro they were
assaulting Democratic institutions
that's the sort of framework that they
applied and so they've had this fake
news investigation that has given them
the pretext to censor journalists arrest
journalists even arrest uh sitting
members of the lower house in Brazil
they put Daniel silver under a house
arrest a lot of ankle bracelets rolling
around there uh and so I knew that going
in to some degree I got educated more on
the ground Jason Miller and I and as
people don't know this is Trump's sort
of campaign Maine comms guy very very
close to Trump very very high profile
figure in his own right and he was
building out getter at the time still is
an alternative to Twitter that uh you
know is more egalitarian Freedom
oriented especially as Twitter was uh
highly uh censored platform as we all
know as I know you know uh and so he was
going to talk about that if CPAC and
promote it uh and I was talking about
you know fairytos and media and I
organized because I am quite friendly
over the years with Eduardo bolsonaro
and other members of the bolsonaro
family I organized a meeting with all of
us in jair Boston hour the sitting
president at the palace and those
pictures that we posted went viral uh
and it turned out that on the Sunday we
were leaving on a Monday on the Sunday
after CPAC had uh had uh concluded uh
news stories broke in the uh
stenographer press the The Guild
carrying mainstream press of Brazil
which actually makes uh CNN here look
downright honest I mean you guys were
really uh really really pravto really
propagandist uh incidentally not
surprisingly they were also on the
payroll of the previous regimes quite
heavily uh state-owned Enterprises were
funding much of their revenue
advertising and whatever else uh so they
reported on a Sunday afternoon before
we're supposed to leave that we'd been
on under surveillance from the moment we
landed and I told Jason you know I spent
a lot of time in Central and Eastern
Europe post-communist Nations I've been
tapped I've been surveilled I've been
watched I've been dragged into to you
know Kangaroo Court hearings uh none of
this stuff surprises me and I told him
and I said uh you know there's a good
chance we're going to be detained at the
airport and he goes no you're being
paranoid I'm not being paranoid I think
it'd be kind of great it would serve the
point perfectly uh I was with dual
citizenship which is kind of helpful uh
and we were so we were leaving on a
Monday to a fly out and before we can
get to our plane uh they say you know
please come with us and they put uh we
had a traveling party of four uh Jason
myself and two uh dual Brazilian uh
American citizens uh that uh that came
with us and also had been involved with
CPAC and they really Jason was the main
one they wanted to talk to and so they
let us sit on the plane uh for a little
bit and three four hours goes by lawyers
are called State Department lawyers
called uh they say well you're screwed
get another lawyer so they weren't very
helpful eventually uh Jason was able to
procure a a good lawyer through
Brazilian context to come and help
extricate us but it became the big story
when we were flying out Politico CNN
Forbes Business Insider they all picked
it up about our detention but it was
very very instructive of how
heavy-handed they are here we are you
know not Brazilians just coming in uh in
a constitutional republic we can come
and speak our ideas well or shall we
thought apparently not without some sort
of repercussion and they wanted to to
probe and understand who we met with to
add to their enemies list so from that
moment on I just said I'm gonna go deep
I'm going to talk to people I'm going to
really understand the history how we got
here the the mechanisms of power that
are in place and being utilized to clamp
down on opposition and I learned a lot
in the in the the following months and I
published on it ahead of the election
and I basically predicted that this
election would be filled with uh you
know to use a generous term anomalies uh
but this even Tucker said it the other
night when I was on the fix was in uh
the fix was in you know the real Genesis
of the fix being in was this court
subsuming all these powers that are
generally broken down in a
constitutional republic they uh they're
very Biz marketing remember Audubon
Bismarck said politics is the art of the
possible they just do it and the the
power assumptions they've done by
censoring journalists by shaping The
Narrative by forcing people and cowing
them into submission uh is overwhelming
you know I wrote in one of my articles
the powers they've taken would make
Mugabe blush it would be akin to in the
U.S if we had one tribunal that had all
the powers of the doj say Merrick
Garland the head of the FBI enforcement
uh subpoena power uh the legislators
power of oversight so say uh uh you know
Gerald Nadler and uh the the recent uh
select committee or unselect committee
uh all of these Powers were on the
Supreme Court of course you know like
Ruth Bader Ginsburg also so if you
wrapped up all these people Eric Holder
everyone who is uh fighting you know the
American right and you gave one body and
one person all of the their powers
combined that's what the Supreme Court
has become and as a result it's up for
quite gross abuse one of their biggest
gross abuses was they hold on let me let
me pause you for a second because
there's a lot here I want to make sure
we don't get ahead of ourselves first
off everything that you just described
there I feel like is basically slow
motion happening in this country in I
mean in this country that we're in right
now uh that's one problem but okay so so
there was a central centralization of
power this is last year first when you
got detained now you're deep into this
thing you're predicting sort of what's
going to happen with the election and I
don't want to get to just because I'm
trying to intro everybody to this I
don't want to get too lost in all of the
weeds of this so let's just flash a
little bit towards the election so it's
a couple days before the election what
were you thinking was going to happen
and can you just describe the two
candidates a little bit because it
really is in essence this is a
capitalist versus socialist fight that's
happening there yeah and and and very
very basic I mean hard right hard left
you know the Brazilian right uh is more
and more uh Evangelical Brazil's always
been Catholic uh Brazil's populism that
bolsonaro uh really became the head of
and he was a legislator before his
career military then he was a legislator
in the lower house a congressman uh they
they called the Chamber of deputies uh
the populism that he came in with to
Brazil was really reactionary obviously
we saw what's going on the whole world
Poland and Hungary uh reacting against
the EU overreach of their Sovereign
capacity on borders on economics and
everything uh Trump brexit so bolsonaro
comes in in 2018 and he obviously is a
conservative he's a right-winger uh very
very strongly aligned with evangelicals
with Israel uh very much a uh believer
in Brazil first and also a a guy warning
about China's uh deep integration into
the ever more communist Latin America
and the important history is why Boston
now is a reaction because before
bolsonaro you had Lula de Silva Dilma
Rousseff and Michael temmer Lula was a
two-term president who was convicted
impeached convicted and sent to jail for
a very very famous maybe one of the
largest public corruption scandals in
the history of the world it's called
operation Car Wash uh you could even the
Wikipedia it's so Brazen and uh overdone
that even the Wikipedia is accurate
because you can't you can't spin wow uh
stolen they call it lava Jato in uh in
Brazil and they were selling under
Lula's presidency uh essentially the
state assets natural resource assets
State assets for cash in bags to the
Chinese to others taking nice uh
commissions for themselves huge money
was changing hands within their cabal
and also very importantly sending money
to Cuba uh via VIA petrogras uh
petrogras is the state Oil Company one
of the biggest in the world uh and they
were helping support Cuba by giving them
free oil even though it's a joint stock
company with International investors so
so very very illegal stuff he was
convicted of a dozen charges by 19
judges and three separate hearings three
separate court trials so when they say
oh well it was uh it was fixed it was
wrong no no three separate tribunals of
19 judges unanimously convicted him of
12 charts and sentenced him to 12 years
in jail his judicial appointees uh him
and Dilma people from his own party they
appoint these judges Supreme Court and
other courts they let him out citing a
jurisdictional technicality now that is
an absolute Canard because he's still
from the entire country so in in sort of
the the jurisprudence along the
Brazilian constitutional lines there are
no jurisdictions where he would not be
eligible for trial because he stole it
from everybody and these judges that
unanimously found him guilty these were
not bolsonaro people these people
predated by bolsonaro by many years and
in fact even the mainstream media uh at
the time was covering it uh even the
military when we talk about the
Brazilian military in the mixed bag of
their political allegiances they were
defending the protesters on the street
when this broke so he goes to jail Dilma
Rousseff his vice president in essence
takes over she ends up impeached and
convicted for the same thing she gets
kicked out of office her vice president
Michael temmer comes in and only serves
out two years very very pro-china when
he left he had seven percent approval uh
which is you know pretty historic lows
for any constitutional republic to have
seven percent approval uh of a head of
state uh bolsonaro got elected on a wave
of this just discontent distrust in the
corruption of this cabal Lula
politically is you know I I read
sometimes in uh mainstream press now
that they are covering it because it's
expedient to do so to further their
narrative he's a socialist he's not a
socialist he's a communist he is a
full-on Marxist hammer and sickles
five-pointed stars in 1990 he co-founded
the Sao Paulo Forum with drumroll please
Fidel Castro and the Genesis of this was
the Soviet Union was breaking down
between 89 and 91 the Soviet Union for
the better part of 50 or 60 years was
feeding money to Cuba and using Cuba as
the base of operations for this
hemisphere to incubate and inculcate
Marxist political movements all over
Latin America so with the Soviet Union
that well-running dry Lula and Fidel
realized they needed to do it and you
couldn't do it out of Cuba uh per se
because of all the sanctions so Lula
created in Brazil the Sao Paulo Forum as
an incubating uh vehicle like a think
tank like a AI on the right or a
Brookings or a world economic Forum to
push the ideas and to teach the
political players and they were very
much behind the rise of chevismo shabbas
Maduro there is no Latin American
Communist that did not go through
Foreigner Fernandez and more recently in
Colombia which was sort of a righty
country because of the reaction against
the Marxist Guerrilla Narco trafficantes
of farc you now have leader named Petro
who also was a Marxist gorilla with
another sort of drug moving Guerrilla
Force he's now had under some
questionable uh election uh election uh
Runnings of the election and then in
Chile another country that sort of
bounced between right and Central left
was never a hard left uh Bolivia or
Venezuela now you've got uh borage a
another student Marxist leader that was
incubated by the Sao Paulo Forum Brazil
is the gold standard Brazil is what they
needed to bring it all together so the
judges released him made him a sort of
figurehead he couldn't go I mean it
sounds familiar he couldn't go out and
campaign much like Biden but you know
when Biden couldn't campaign it was
because there was no enthusiasm when
Lula couldn't campaign it's because if
he went into public and walked down the
street he'd be ripped Lynn from limb
like Gaddafi he's not liked everybody in
the country I even was on a Twitter
spaces the other day and I even got the
Communists who were on the spaces in
this debate to conceive oh yeah of
course he was guilty of public
corruption everybody knows that which I
started tweeting at them that they
admitted that for their base uh so all
right so wait let let's pause for a
second so okay so there's a lot here so
I want to make sure everyone's following
all this so you have the Communist that
was in charge for a while there's all
this corruption he's basically selling
the country off to China piece by piece
eventually he gets released starts this
forum you you've explained how this sort
of got exported so this is yeah so he
built his political
so now this is sort of exported all
through the region now this get now
let's get then baldnessaro takes over he
has a couple pretty good years actually
but then we have this election so get us
caught up really starting a little bit
before the election because I want
people to understand really what some of
the because we're going to show some
b-roll as you're talking of the protests
and everything post-election but I want
people to understand why there are these
people out there what they are doing and
how our media is trying to really really
paint them in this you know these are
the ultra magical Republicans that are
out there doing all this stuff yeah no
this is a silent majority Center I mean
these are not you know oath keeper proud
boys as much as they like to spin it uh
so very very important is that in
bolsonaro comes in an 18 and very very
quickly he the rallies around him are
driven toward the debate over elections
because people know nobody much like
Hillary Clinton and Trump they didn't
expect bolsonaro to win uh the The
Establishment The leftist Establishment
the courts the media they thought they
would be fine both scenario actually won
and I really believe that it was uh you
know this sort of circumstance he got
stabbed while on the campaign Trail and
was all he was almost assassinated
almost murdered and the strength he
showed inspired a lot of people he was
back on the camp training I mean he was
near death he was in the ICU and then
he's back on the campaign Trail and he
eeks in the Victory and of course now
they're apocalyptic now they have to go
especially aggressive The Establishment
and how do we undermine him and how do
we make sure this doesn't happen again
uh very very important data point when
he was in Congress he sponsored a bill
that was passed to have backup paper
ballots to the electronic voting
machines which they started using a
certain Venezuelan company in 2016. uh
and people kind of knew we don't trust
their Latin American democracies because
we're this is not like uh you know us
thinking back a hundred years ago this
is for them 20 30 years ago what Latin
America looked like military
dictatorships uh heavily Marxist rule in
many of the countries it kind of bounces
back and forth and so people knew that
you know there are always one step away
from going back to that and so massive
rallies in the street give us paper I
was there in Brazilia when I saw a rally
and the Chance are give us paper ballots
that is what they want so he pushes a
bill in 16 that uh you know four backup
paper ballots Dilma was present at the
time she vetoes it citing you'll love
this the cost so the machines themselves
are 20 000 bucks a printer is a hundred
bucks uh and she's like well this is
fiscally irresponsible to put a printer
in the uh not everybody knew that was a
a BS a BS uh you know reasoning so if
you just borrow the money from China
yeah well I mean it's it's a de minimis
cost right now printers the beauty of
capitalism prices go down uh so it goes
back to Congress Congress overrides The
veto that never happens Brazilian
parliamentary Congressional politics
legislative politics very fragment it's
not like two parties like 10 parties and
really five frames Center left hard left
Center center right hard right and then
multiple parties in each one
overwhelming support for this in the
legislature and then so it now override
for veto gets passed Supreme Court
strikes it down citing privacy issues uh
so they were very at war with paper
ballots because they knew that that
would be auditable uh so now he's you
know talking about this as president uh
and people are obviously nervous uh
coming in because they let Lula out of
prison Lula and they're citing all the
international press will is back out a
technicality absolute nonsense you know
because of the criminality was so high
everybody knew it so now the court is
going full interference mode in Every
Which Way arresting and censoring
journalists well great journalist here
in the US Alando Santos uh he's like
Brazil's Tucker Carlson I mean like if
you could hit one journalist who
represents the voice of the people from
a conservative and right-wing
perspective uh he's been Exiles they
ransacked his house and he escaped and
claimed Asylum here he has sort of a
sort of temporary Asylum and more
recently they've revoked his passport
and put out Interpol red notices for him
this is how heavy-handed they are they
arrested uh sitting members of Congress
dozens of journalists well as I
mentioned before a lot of ankle braces a
lot of Home detentions uh Frozen bank
accounts D platforming they started
going after big Tech and saying anytime
we send you somebody to D platform you
have to take them off or we will find
you if you ignore the fines we will come
after you we will kick you out of the
country and even even Facebook initially
and YouTube pushed back we're talking
like four years ago or so they said no
we don't see grounds for a social media
suspension or a blacklist or a band and
they said well we don't care if you see
grounds if you don't do it we're going
to raid your servers and kick you out of
the country and by the way this this uh
Supreme Court has their own federal
police force like an FBI that's loyal to
them so they have real power real muscle
behind you know what does the Supreme
Court supposed to do in a constitutional
republic adjudicate legislation if it's
constitutional or not they're so far
beyond that and the guy who runs it
wasn't a judge he was a prosecutor he's
a very famous zealous political
prosecutor from Sao Paulo that timer
pointed this guy Alexander Marias for
anybody who like is researching Brazil
looks at my articles or anything on
social media he's the guy who looks like
a Brazilian Lex Luthor uh he looks
exactly like Lexi I mean a big [ __ ]
grin on his face drunk with power uh and
he's literally he just has anybody he
doesn't like arrested uh so Boston hour
tried to fight back on it but he was
kind of hamstrung the legislature wasn't
overwhelmingly for bolsonaro either I
mean very fragmented so now you have
leading into the election all the polls
done by The Usual Suspects the
mainstream press globo volha the
equivalent of CNN are saying that Lula
is up by like 20 points he's going to
win in a in a landslide well the end of
the first round Lulu was up by three or
four points neither got over 50 and
really as I believe I proved in uh my
CDM media I I write for an R uh a outlet
called cdm.press uh the Publisher's name
is Todd wood ex-military he does not
afraid of anything so he'll publish me I
touched some third rails uh and I I did
some statistical analysis with a
international group of forensic Auditors
and analysts in electoral distributions
political science and what we saw in
just the first round let alone second
round was that Boston hour was well up
initially until the ballot drops skewed
after the first 10 or so percent of
precincts every single one therein was
55-45 Lula including in regions I mean
certainly in regions where we're
historical leftist strongholds poorer
areas in the Amazon a lot of indigenous
tribes people used to vote for for Lula
for Dilma for the for the Socialist
programs like Bolsa Familia
redistributing wealth well it turns out
that in those precincts there were zero
votes for bolsonaro which was so Brazen
because many of the Baltimore did bring
a lot of people together people really
did like him on the ground and they
ended up in these marches and as protest
leaders the indigenous tribal leaders
and they have special rights in the
Brazilian Constitution they they don't
have it's almost like a American Indian
Native American reservations there's
sort of a dual uh legal code and some
things apply to them some things don't
and so they were leading the protest
movements as well and the chief of the
the Givenchy tribe so Sarah is still in
jail from January 12th on my Intel tells
me they've been torturing him trying to
get him to sign up didn't a
self-denunciation and public apology to
Marias this is coming from his family
and his fellow tribe members so the the
first round they're marching because
they're like no we did vote for Boston
hour there's no way in these precincts
in our region that there were zero votes
so we know that there was gross fraud in
the second round the clampdowns came
down because there's a first round if
you don't win a simple majority and
there was like six or seven candidates
nobody got over 50 percent so it goes to
a runoff between bolsonaro and uh and
Lula uh four weeks after the first round
October 2nd Sunday October 2nd then
Sunday October 30th and then the same
exact thing happens in the second round
Bolson hour is way up initially uh and
then the ballot drops start 50 by 45
give or take until they both cross over
both the first round and second round
they crossed over to a Lula lead at
66.66 of pre-sense reporting which is
like you know and by the way if you're a
mathematician mathematician the standard
deviation sort of differentials and
Fibonacci level 66.6 is a very important
number in statistics for a reason and so
it was kind of interesting with the
algorithms how it's it somehow ended up
there uh so so okay again let me let me
pause you for a sec so basically there's
all this corruption he's running on this
idea that we have to secure our
elections this actually sounds there's a
reason I wanted to do this for my
audience that mostly focuses on American
politics the themes here obviously are
are transcending borders so then they
okay there's the first one there's the
second one and now people are going
something something really isn't right
because what they're seeing out of the
media is really not matching up with
what they're seeing on the ground again
it sort of seems familiar between the
first round and second round in the
first round
Bolson hours party did unprecedentedly
well regions that they never secured
governorships or senators or lower house
legislators they never had that
representation his party on the strength
of his endorsement alone one handily
unprecedented how much 27 19 out of 27
one-third of the Senate seats 81 Senate
seats are up one-third of them and he
got 19 out of that one-third 27. that is
a massive mandate governorships uh so
down ballot everybody performed well and
these are not people who even had
political identities their entire
identity was predicated in fact Bolson
said okay go for this guy and they won
easily so again everyone's like
um something's wrong in the state of
Brazil to paraphrase Hamlet
they start marching on the second round
uh the day after October 30th so October
31st that Monday that was the first I'm
sure you should show some of this
footage yeah so we'll we'll play some
footage right now just to that you can
keep going and we're just going to show
you because these were extraordinary
images we're not talking tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands we're
not even talking Millions we're talking
eight figures people in the streets not
just in Brasilia or the major you know
cities like Sao Paulo and Rio or below
Horizonte we're talking leftist
strongholds in the North like Recife
every city in the country their Town
Square was filled with people screaming
about this saying no we and you know
part of it they also know communism they
don't want to be Communists and they
know Lula is a a an actual communist uh
and so the protests are massive and as I
was saying on you know a lot of the
appearances the revolution will not be
televised not a single Reuters dispatch
BBC NBC NPR nothing silence globo their
fake news media decides that they want
to prove to the world how there are no
protests so they go to a back alley and
go see nobody's here that's how gross
and prabhda and Soviet and Brazen it is
uh the protests accelerate into the
certification the certification and by
the way very important there is the
Supreme Court which is the the you know
creme dollar crime of the pyramidal
distribution of Judiciary but right
under the Supreme Court is the electoral
Court the Tribune Superior electoral
guess what they do they oversee the
elections administer the elections guess
who's the head of it the same chief
justice appointed himself from the
Supreme Court Alexander Morris as head
of the Electoral court so he's been head
of the Electoral Court as well and uses
that as anytime somebody leading into
the election between the first and the
second round after the second round says
the election might have been fraudulent
electoral Court says you're assaulting
the Democratic institution you're uh
besmirching the faith and integrity of
our elections you're under arrest your
bank account's Frozen you've been
de-platformed on social media so gross
abuses soviet-style uh in power now the
military wakes up and they say well the
Constitution says in article 142 we have
the role in society of when there's a
separation of powers dispute to
adjudicate and as we have now the
Judiciary is at odds with the executive
branch and so it's the military's job to
adjudicate it so they file a petition to
audit the machines the tabulation date
and the source code which is very much
their constitutional right and
responsibility the Electoral Court says
pound sand they ignore it entirely
military puts out a 65-page audit report
that says well we can't give anything
conclusive because they wouldn't let us
near the actual evidence
then right after that you've got the
head of the party uh but Boston hours
Party part the Liberal Party PL say to
file to court we also we found fraud
we're petition the court to address this
they say this is nonsense you are guilty
of fraud by telling us that we are
possibly fraudulent we're going to find
your party 22 million five six million
bucks and now you're under criminal
investigation for fake news and
assaulting Democratic institutions so I
mean we see a pattern here yes there is
something going on the vice Titans more
and more now I said this uh you know
bolsonaro did not you know Prevail in
this election the trend towards
Venezuela would be very very quick and I
am even shocked with my cynicism how
quick it's been so now we have you know
the military does fail to act and invoke
martial law I believe bolsonaro was
pushing that he had some generals behind
him some not behind him in the end he
leaves Lula comes in and now you have
this protest that was very well
telegraphed I mean I was seeing stuff
all over social media we're marching on
Brazilia into three powers squared three
power squares the picture where you have
this sort of sunken in giant field in
between the three major buildings the
National Congress the Supreme Court and
the uh the presidential executive branch
Palace the uh uh Palo Alto I forget not
Palo Alto that's where you guys are from
but so uh and they march to this and now
we already have videos after the fog of
war that show there were Asian
provocateurs already in the National
Congress taking hammers to the windows
screwing up all the chairs ripping stuff
off the wall waiting for the throngs of
people to enter and then hey guys come
in the water's nice they came in you
have videos of the protesters and by the
way it's almost like a kind of Kumbaya
like you've never seen such a
cross-section Society every race male
and female every age 10 year old kids 80
year old men and women all together and
then they're arguing with the agent
provocateurs no don't break that yeah
rip that off the wall don't you know
don't bang a chair until the legs fall
off like they're arguing we have tons of
videos of this uh then the National
Guard the federal police come in and
they have a little bit of a standoff
with the military police who are
generally defending the protesters
because the military's job is to defend
the Constitution not to defend the
judicial autocracy and takeover of the
country and the shredding of the
Constitution and there's a little
standoff the federal police Prevail they
put the protesters in buses to start off
with 400 then it was 1200. the last
number I heard was that they captured
about 1700 people and they bring them to
the federal police training facility in
Brasilia uh stick them in the gymnasium
no food no water no bathrooms young kids
no food old women uh dehydrated uh
Intel says and it's been pretty well
verified that at least one person's died
that day I heard two people now they say
it's up to four or five uh and they
basically create a gulag which are being
called in Brazil lulox Lula gulags yeah
Fort Monto uh and now after two days of
that that was Monday and Tuesday they
let the women and children go uh by the
way the images of old people sitting in
puddles of their own urine because
they're no bathrooms sweltering
conditions no food no water uh they let
the older the older women and the women
and children go and on the condition
that we have these floating around a
denunciation page you have to sign it to
be released saying I am a terrorist I
assault a democracy and this now has
them on lists they will never get a job
again uh and they take all the men and I
guess some of the more able-bodied
younger women uh they're now in a
federal the equivalent of a federal
penitentiary no due process they have
not had access to to a council uh we
have videos uh that have been leaked
that show just kill us already you've
basically taken everything to despair
the despondency and the whole country
and now of course they're clamping down
they just shut down yesterday Brazil's
version of Fox News Jovan Palm it is
shut down by Fiat so now there's no
alternative media whatsoever they've
shut down everybody on the right social
media the lists of of people who've been
de-platformed on social media is now
into the tens of thousands uh and
they're clapping down now they uh
Alexander Demarest has suspended the
governor of the federal district a state
where Brasilia is uh is a part of uh
suspended the governor for 90 days he
doesn't have the power to do it but he
did it uh saying that well you uh did
not help us defend it I went on Tucker
and said that a senator who's not a
pulse now a party member at all found
documents uh there were documents
submitted by security agencies to Flavio
Dino the Justice Minister and Lula
saying that there was going to be unrest
on Sunday we should cordon off the
building so that it's not of you know an
Insurrection and I mean it kind of
reminds you of Nancy Pelosi who the
Capitol Hill report to I mean right the
Tucker said it as well you know template
now so all these pieces I think people
are following along even if they're
missing some of the the specifics uh
that you're talking about the the big
pieces here all feel very familiar to a
lot of things that have been happening
across the west and even the way our
mainstream media was ignoring everything
for months then finally the events of of
basically the last week happen and they
can start just claiming that it's a
bunch of interest insurrectionists and
this is this is Maga exported and the
rest of it and that's what we're seeing
out of all of our Democrat politicians
the ones who are speaking about it and
out of our media Machinery so to someone
yeah I'm reading that you know I read in
Vanity Fair and Politico and Washington
Post that you know this was coordinating
Tucker uh alluded to this this now the
media is covering this right the
revolution wouldn't be televised for for
eight weeks right when they got what
they when they got the images they
wanted then all of a sudden I'm getting
asked for comment and all of a sudden
I'm reading I I organized her because I
was covering it or Bannon because I've
been doing war room every day on it
Bannon understands Global communism so
we've been covering this for even months
leading in that Brazil has been the most
important electoral Battleground in 2022
against Global communism against China
coming into Latin America and uh
creating the orwellian super state if
you had 1984 Oceana East Asia that's
Lula's goal he wants a South American
super State he's already floated one
currency there's always at War if you if
you exactly uh they were always at War
until they're not and then history gets
revised uh they want one currency which
if you thought the Euro was a bad idea
with Southern uh Italy and Spain with
Germany and uh and Amsterdam Netherlands
uh two different types of economies
merging into one currency all the
problems that's created how do you have
Venezuela a absolute communist rat hole
that's been created out of the South
Forum Sao Paulo and Brazil one of the
wealthiest nations in the world third
largest economy in our hemisphere second
largest countries third after U.S Canada
220 million people wealthy in oil gas
magnesium manganese bauxite 10 copper
gold uh third or fourth largest food
producer to the world wheat barley oats
you know this is a big deal that com
that China is going to have a very
controlled puto and by the way also
important I don't believe Lula's the
president of the country I mean he is a
in in a name he's a figurehead they let
him out of prison so they could have a
figurehead they can have somebody that
they could spin the people were with him
it's Alexander Morris it has been
wholesale taken over by the head of the
judicial autocracy the Supreme Court
judge and electoral Court Judge who's
taken all these powers and has
weaponized them against political
opposition you know what they're saying
now they're saying they are not going to
seat the right-wing legislators in the
legislature
this is right they're just not going to
put them on they because they're
terrorists because now after January 8th
uh you know some of these Nicholas
Pereira is a young congressman who got
more votes than anybody else in any of
the ballots in Brazilian history
and they are not going to seat him
because he tweeted that you know this is
the elections fraudulent that Mariah
says out of control so the terror Carlos
and belly be a kisses like hardcore
political righties are not only going to
be not seated many of them are going to
be put in jail very very soon so this
has gone from zero to Stalin in record
time I thought it'd be Venezuela in six
to 12 months well it's going to be you
know the post-bolshevik order in Russia
in 1920 21 when the first uh Soviet
government was formed it is going to be
that show trials purges uh probably
gulags and mass executions that's what
these people are capable of okay so in
the in the remaining moments again
there's there's just so much here you're
giving us a lot and we'll we'll do this
again and and I want people to pay
attention to this because even when I I
think I retweeted one or two of the
videos that you had posted and the
amount of people that I saw responses
from saying we're in Brazil everyone's
ignoring us we're not terrorists we're I
mean all the stuff it's just like
they're being ignored or manipu you know
what people are saying about them is a
complete manipulation of the truth so at
the moment I think bonasaros here in
Florida people have taken videos people
have taken videos of him uh basically
wandering around Publix and seeing
what's going on over here but did he so
did he technically flee I mean was that
was that a midnight job you know he
failed in his attempt to uh fight back
with the fraudulent election uh the
Judiciary uh got to I guess some of the
judges threatened to arrest some of the
I'm sorry the Judiciary got some of the
generals threatened to arrest him have
still threatened to arrest him now if
they don't go and weaponize their forces
against the protesters uh he was not
able to get article 142 invoked so on
the 30th and you know if you're a head
of state uh the American uh sort of Visa
program is you can come in and out as
you please so he had to leave before his
term was up on midnight the 31st and
Lula was sworn in but he also I know him
personally he didn't want to be a part
there's a uh the the the sort of
Changing of the Guard has a symbolic
object where you hand the sash over you
present the sash he didn't want to be a
part of that he knows what this is so
between that the symbolic Optics and
having to get out because the second if
he was there they would have arrested
him that day they would have put him in
jail that day and now they're going to
try an extraditum uh he has telegraphed
that he will go back to Brazil uh he may
go into Exile in Italy for instance his
family has an Italian background and I
think the Maloney government would give
him Refuge uh I suggested to them go to
Hungary they'll give a lot of people
Refuge uh but he's going to go back now
I believe uh in short order but it it's
not going to end well for him and he
said this to Jason and myself when we
met with them this is going to end one
of three ways in my arrest my death or
my victory in prevailing and uh it
doesn't look like Victory and prevailing
is going to happen so uh now he did go
to Florida which I thought was
personally I I would have gone to Italy
and put in a caretaker government by
force but hey I'm not a Brazilian
politician so
not yet anyway I mean he said he did not
want to have Civil War uh his
fingerprints on Civil War my argument on
that I know that you know Vanity Fair
and Politico they'll have a field day
with this is Civil War you have an
option of winning and you probably would
have won because the military by and
large was with you 170 of the highest
ranking officers in an unprecedented uh
act signed an open letter two most
narrow publicized in media we need you
to act and invoke article 142 otherwise
we are going to be Venezuela uh well he
didn't and now it is Venezuela but even
more it took the shabba's a few years to
really cement power he got power
democratically elected coercively so but
democratically elected it wasn't until
he held a sham referendum to cement
power I think it was in 2002 that it got
really brutal and oppressive and they
went after dissidents uh and and really
took just unilateral control of the
country this is happening in Brazil
within a week
so in essence he's in Exile we'll see
where he ends up Lulu is the I suppose
titular head of state but you're saying
he's not even really in charge we'll see
what happens to all of the quote-unquote
insurrectionists the media will lie
about pretty much everything well I
guess in summation where should people
go to find out more if more of something
approximate to honesty related to all of
this because if you turn on CNN for the
little bit or you know the one article
they might that might be on the second
page over at cnn.com it's basically as I
said it's the Maga insurrectionists
trying to destroy democracy just like
they did in America well one of the
powerful things of Brazilian populism is
that Brazil is I think and I'd love to
see quantitative metrics on this the
most social media engaged country and
citizenry in the world uh everybody's on
social media and they're active they're
engaged they use technology very
effectively there is no shortage of
Prima fascia evidence from the ground of
what has transpired and what's
continuing to transpire obviously I'm a
Hobbit spoke for it I've become a bit of
English language voice and Global
Western press especially in the U.S for
them so my my Twitter my getter my
Instagram obviously have blown up on
this it's I feel like I better learn
Portuguese otherwise I won't be able to
use my own news feed uh so it's very
very social media engaged up until a few
days ago you did have a sort of
alternative media and right Wingers but
they've literally been shut down by Fiat
Joven Pawn uh the the right Wingers the
journalists and conservatives who are in
this country are all now going to be
pushed to be extradited back and be put
in prison uh Paolo figarito uh Rodrigo
Constantino uh uh Ricardo Martinez who's
a pastor they want to put him in jail
they want to I'm getting messages
they're so heartbreaking the despondency
from the people I have people have been
sources for me now for for months and
especially in the last couple months
saying I'm shutting down all my social
media to remove the tracks so that they
don't break down my door at 5am tomorrow
and put a paper bag or a a cloth bag
over my head and rendition me and you
know my father was an anti-common
assistant in Poland imprisoned by the
Soviets in Lithuania dealing with the
polls censored and harassed non-stop for
being a dissonant so I know you know
what this looks like and it basically
looks like a Kafka story where you know
you get a bag over your head at 5am and
then your wife goes to the police
station says uh my husband was taken by
the government they go oh no you just
misplaced him we don't know what you're
talking about
man there there is a lot here I I
appreciate you packing it a lot in a
short amount of time uh we'll link to
your social media accounts below so
people can follow you more specifically
on the day-to-day stuff what's going on
here but uh keep it up man and uh maybe
we'll bump into
him someday at Publix you know what I
mean maybe I don't know I think he's
probably not going to have that uh
freewheeling a lifestyle going forward
thank you Matthew thank you David if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell